hey everybody it's Mike from Immortal
flows and welcome back to my channel on
order flow trading
um you know lately I've been talking a
lot
um about imbalances and yesterday I got
into you know trading in areas where
there's lack of volume and again you
know when a lot of people think of order
flow trading they think of the old days
you know with the the Traders standing
around in the office in the 1920s or
1930s you know you've seen them all
those old movies guys stand around this
vacuum tube looking at the ticker tape
right and they're analyzing for big
trades now that is one part of analyzing
order flow right you do want to be aware
of you know where the big volumes are
going through and you know when you
start getting into other markets though
you know it's not as uh as easy as that
because you know like in the e-minis
right which is what most people trade or
even the uh NASDAQ or even mnq
um you know big volume stands out but
what if you're trading in a market that
trades big volume right like the
treasury notes the 10 years the en on
the Chicago Board of Trade right and you
can see at Price levels you know it's
trading ten thousand contracts now this
is a four range chart I prefer to look
at treasuries on a four range chart I've
done this for over a decade
um looking at the far range chart I
don't really see a need to deviate to a
different type of chart if you're trying
honestly if you're trying to look at it
uh the footprint on a one minute chart
it's going to be difficult to really
you know wrap your head around and try
and make decisions right this is a
simple
one minute chart on the treasuries and
let me just make a quick adjustment here
to the Candlestick size I'll expand it
up here and if the market is basically
trading One Price like here at 109.30
for the bar you're not gonna be able to
really get much out of that right you're
going to need some sort of movement some
sort of solid aggression because in this
case the market is just basically
trading the bid in the offer right just
these as over here right so that's why I
like to look at treasuries because they
tend to be slower moving markets but
they trade big size you know for example
right we just traded in one minute here
11.51 on the bid when it was 109 30 bid
1379 when it was 109.30 offer so you
know close to 33 000 contracts those two
and a half thousand contracts
um in that one minute
but it's just trading one price so you
know how are you going to analyze that
it's difficult to really analyze that
because you got big buying on the bid
big buying on the offer and what I sell
settled on years ago is watching a range
based chart in uh treasuries like uh
bonds
um 10 years five years
Etc that trade generally decent sized
volumes that make the chart easier to
read because you know at the end of the
day you know you want to be using a
chart that's going to help you
understand what you're looking at
especially in the order flow and like I
said you know this is a market that
trades big size there's always big size
on the bid big size on the offer and big
size that's going through right you can
see down here when it traded all the way
down to 109 31 and a half
6429 transacted on the bid
6239 transacted on the offer so you know
that that's a lot of volume
um going through so trying to If you're
looking at Big volume only
where's the value right it's a market
that trades big volume so what I I've
always liked to look at in treasuries
and you know even in in other markets is
areas of small volume okay so for
example today right we we're going up
making new highs we made a new high
around 9 11 and then started coming off
made a run back up to that high and you
trade three contracts here on the offer
one uh ten six and a half right just
three contracts so what happened 245 on
the offer up here but again as you're
going up it's trading a lot of volume 8
000 on the offer 5 000 on the offer you
see this
strong volume all through these bars six
thousands four thousand five thousand
four thousand then it comes up here it
trades three huh three
what's that telling you right there's no
it's telling you it's screaming at you
hey there's no interest up here right
just three contracts traded
and then it starts selling off so if I
know right if I know that just three
contracts trade and how do I know I just
look at my freaking charge it shows me
that you know it's about putting the
pieces of the puzzle together you know
you're
uh having a pullback up to this high and
again you know if you're going back up
to the high what's your thought oh maybe
we could break through the high and go
higher well what do you need to do that
you need buying you need strong
aggressive buying and if you look up
here and you see only three contracts
the Market's telling you hey
Traders aren't interested up here
they're not interested to take it any
higher because it maybe the move got
exhausted whatever nobody's interested
that's the important thing Market starts
coming down so rallies back up it's
still got that area here three contracts
traded you get one tick below trades
some volume you know 500 on the bid 871
on the offer
nobody's interested trade it back up
here at six and a half Market starts
coming off you can see this buyer trades
one comes off trades some decent volume
down here right the six thousand you
know about close to uh
almost thirteen thousand contracts about
twelve and a half thousand contracts
bounces back up going back up okay well
maybe you know this is going to be our
intermediate low and we're going to
start rallying back up and then you see
four right sort of the same thing here
right you saw the three right you sold
off came back up three sold off starting
to come back up four then the market
sells off and it's it's just a market
just all you got to do is just look at
the market it's not rocket science right
just by seeing these areas of thin
volume is going to
um you know put you way out there in
front of everybody else that's not
looking at volume because you know if
people are following price action
um you know or fibs right they're going
to take the low to the high here I don't
know what this is let's draw a let's get
a fib tool here where's my drawing tools
Christmas go for the low
to the high you know oh here's your 50
retracement right in here this is 61.8
so you know we're right around the 50
and you know I know a lot of people they
they will do this they will buy they'll
draw the
line from the low to the high look for
the 50 retracement and just buy it right
there that's why it was probably why
there's a lot of volume transacting down
here there's 5 000 on the bid here 6400
that's right at 50 percent 110 even you
get this bounce up you know they're
looking for the market to go up take out
this high and go higher that is a
legitimate training strategy I also look
for 50 retracements I even have a
special tool for that but uh more on
that later
but then you start rallying
and it just runs out of steam here
trades four contracts okay well what do
you think the Market's telling you again
it's telling you the same thing buyers
aren't interested to take it higher and
you see the market sells off sells off
sells off too basically to the close of
the day now
let me just get this off my
chart there
um you know we do have a tool on again
if you're looking at a normal footprint
chart on a market like 10 years you
could see that plain as a day right
you'd have to have uh cataracts not to
see that but we have a tool right on
order flows Trader
in the settings exhaustion prints okay
and what that's going to do is going to
draw out these areas or highlight these
areas where there's potential exhaustion
coming in the markets
right here you can see it here here even
there's some here so don't you want to
know that you're up here near the high
of the day and you're seeing some signs
of exhaustion if you're at the high of
the day and you're seeing uh buying
exhaustion right because it's coming at
the top of these red candles that's a
bearish sign just as if you're at you
know sort of the off the low of the day
and you're seeing
um
exhaustion here in this case is bullish
exhaustion you know the the sellers are
getting tired of you know trading down
into the lows it's going to give you a
potential nice move
okay it's just nice to have these things
drawn on your chart like here this was
last night right at the high of the day
three contracts
you know here we hit the high of the day
start selling off one contract
okay yeah the three here into the new
highs high of the day five contracts
um let's just go back you know there was
remember last week there was something
that really stood out is add a few more
days here really quick
um
all right let me scroll over here
okay that was there
now
this day we had a very big move down I
had set it at five okay so I'm just
seeing volumes of
five or less this is seven right still a
small number eight or sorry nine here
but look at this up here right
you hit uh the swing high up here 27 you
sort of come off going sideways three
two and then it drops
and
all right again very similar this was on
what the the eighth is very similar to
what it looked like today right you hit
your high sort of start coming off rally
back up five contracts sell off rally
back up one contract and sell off
okay so again it's overflow is just not
about looking for areas of heavy volume
you also want to pay attention to these
areas where there's light volume okay
and again you know most of us trade
uh e-minis mes mnq and Q but you know
these there's a lot of other markets out
there honestly I see a lot of Traders
posting stuff on on these groups that
I'm in
um about how trading is so difficult and
then I started reading on about you know
what they're trying to train NASDAQ
right they're using like a a four point
stop in the NASDAQ and you know four
points stop in the NASDAQ is you're
gonna get blown out you know pretty
quick sometimes
um you know and things like that so
there's plenty of other markets that you
can focus on other than the stock
indices that could give you great trades
I mean you know if you're trading 10
years right
all you got to do if you position
yourself right you catch the major trend
your goal then for the day right you
don't need to be scalping in and out you
can trade it more and more relaxed uh
pace and again you know expand your
trading Horizon besides just the stock
indices right especially sometimes you
know you feel like trading stock indices
at the end of the day you know you feel
like you've been you know swimming
upstream or in a wrestling match and
you're just exhausted
um there's plenty of other markets out
there that can give you uh you know
golden opportunities that you can take
advantage of that just stand out like
what you're seeing here on the 10-year
notes
all right everyone so thanks I hope you
found this video helpful if you did
please be sure to subscribe to the
channel and I'll catch you guys on the
next video bye bye